- [Interviewer] Okay, Kelly.
Kelly, where are you from originally?
- Um, I was born in Long Beach
and grew up in the city
of Hawaiian Gardens.
- [Interviewer] And you grew
up with, uh, both parents?
- No
- [Interviewer] Who, uh, who?
- My mom, she was a single working parent
and she worked most of the day,
so we barely even got to see her.
- [Interviewer] Oh, Really?
- Yeah. My dad left when
we were, when I was five.
- [Interviewer] And how was
your childhood being alone
a lot of the time?
- Well, it was kind of like,
I dunno, besides being alone
I was sexually molested by a stranger
at age eight and then
was abused by my sister,
like physically beaten.
Um, then age 12, like 11
and a half to 12 years old,
I was sexually fondled by
my uncle, my mom's brother.
So, not once but twice.
- [Interviewer] How, how
did you get the first thing,
the first person that molested you?
- The molestation?
- [Interviewer] Who was the stranger?
- Um, I don't know who he was.
- [Interviewer] He just found
you at a park or something?
- Yeah, well age eight,
an eight year old child
shouldn't be left alone,
but I played volley tennis.
So I went, I guess my
sister dropped me off,
and then after my volley tennis practice
I was just hanging in the park
until somebody came to pick
me up, which never happened
Cause I ended up running into
this guy, made up a story
about how his daughter lost
her charm bracelet or something
and he don't know.
So eight year old,
innocent eight year old
child wouldn't know.
So I fell into that trap.
I mean, I was only eight. I
didn't know anything really,
but you know that's
just the kind of person
I was at that age.
I was really friendly and didn't think,
uh, take a second glance
at people that could have been
strangers or harmful to me.
So I went through the whole park
helping him supposedly look
for this charm bracelet
his daughter lost.
We ended up across the
street at the high school
and he physically forced me
to perform oral sex on him
at age eight.
So, and then age 12, my
mom's brother, who happens to
be my uncle, would fondle my breasts
and I told my mom and she
like, she didn't care.
Um, I've been through a
lot of situations, like,
I've been, I'm 41 years old now.
I came to Downtown Lee
after the sexually, the
sexual fondling my uncle.
At age 12 is when I came to Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] You came here at 12?
- Age 12.
- [Interviewer] You've
been out here since 12?
- Mmhm.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- When I wasn't in jail or
rehab or you know, whatever.
But other than that, yeah,
pretty much from age 12 to
41 is pretty much downtown.
I've been through a lot.
I met a lot of people, you know.
Some good, some not so good,
but yeah. Um, I don't know.
- [Interviewer] What's, uh,
what is your drug you use?
- [Kelly] Um, cocaine.
- [Interviewer] When did
you start using that?
- [Kelly] Sometimes crack, age
12 was crack cocaine, yeah.
And, well I kinda tested
with weed for a little bit
and then I went from that to crack cocaine
and I tried crystal but the only drug
I haven't used is heroin.
I've never used it.
- [Interviewer] And, you
have children your own?
- [Kelly] Yes, I have four boys.
- [Interviewer] And, did you raise them?
- [Kelly] No, because of my addiction.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Who raised them?
- [Kelly] Um, my oldest
and my third boy was raised
by my sister, who lives,
one of my older sister
lives in Riverside.
My second oldest, he got adopted
out cause he had a lot of,
cause I used practically my
whole pregnancy with him.
And, which, like at that point
in time the way my life was
going, like, even when I first found out
I was pregnant with him
I was pretty far along.
Like I really didn't care
anymore cause my life wasn't,
you know, I felt like my
life wasn't worth living.
So I tried to figure out a
way, not to kill the baby,
but to kill myself, but I was doing it
to both of us at the same time, so.
- [Interviewer] Did you
know you were pregnant?
- Not at first, no.
cause like my first one
I wasn't on drugs, so
that was like one of the
clean times that I had.
So, I found out when I was pregnant,
when I found out with my
oldest son I was pregnant,
I was like already three
months before I found out.
And, um, my second one, I
didn't know I was pregnant
so that's pretty much why I used
practically my whole pregnancy
- [Interviewer] Do you have
contact with any of your kids?
- My second oldest, who
happens to be the one
that had respiratory
problems when he was born.
And he's in the army and stuff like that
and he's doing a lot better.
I communicate with him often.
- [Interviewer] And what are
you doing for money out here?
- Um, I don't prostitute myself.
Sometimes if I like what
I use for personal use,
I'll take some of that
and if somebody asks me,
"Hey, you have this amount?"
Okay, I'll toss it out to
them to keep my habit going
cause I value myself as a woman
a lot more than I used to.
I'm not going to say I've never done that
because it would be a lie.
But, like, I respect myself and
value myself more as a woman
now today, even though I still
do what I do, I don't have to
put myself out there like
that or put myself at risk
of getting killed by somebody,
you know, dating a woman,
but like, has this ink for
dating, like, sexually,
to have sexual relations with a woman
and they end up doing
horrible things to the woman.
I don't, I can't put
myself at risk like that,
I just can't see myself doing that.
- [Interviewer] And what, any goals here
for the next five years?
- Um, I haven't really
thought that far ahead because
every time I try to, like,
like people, some people
say you don't plan things ahead
because those might fall through.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been clean before?
- Yeah, I have actually.
- [Interviewer] How'd you get clean?
- Um, I did it myself. Yeah
- [Interviewer] Then what
triggered you to go back?
- [Kelly] A lot of
things, like old thoughts,
Thoughts about old
people, places and things.
That's usually what
triggers people to come back
to using and stuff, but.
- [Interviewer] All right,
Kelly thank you so much
for talking to me. Good
luck with everything